Congress is shifting focus to
immigration reform starting with a
procedural vote in the Senate today the
president spelled out three priorities
over the weekend securing the border
ending so-called chained migration
within families and stopping the visa
lottery the president did not mention
daca the program he intends to phase out
it protected young immigrants brought to
the US illegally as children CBS News
contributor ed O'Keefe is a
congressional reporter for The
Washington Post
good morning had happy Monday we're glad
to have you here what's happening in the
Senate with this immigration they're
kind of going back to the future John
they're gonna they're gonna do things
the way they're supposed to do in the
way they used to do it years ago Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell snatched
a bill off the shelf last week something
random that you know would pass if they
ever brought it up on its own and said
look we're gonna use it as the shell and
you can change this bill with
immigration proposals so long as it gets
at least 60 votes of support because you
got to clear those those cloture rules
and at this point we're expecting
Democrats Republicans separately
Democrats and Republicans together to
bring forward a bunch of proposals and
see what if anything can get 60 votes in
the Senate and this is like the old days
because the sense actually doing its job
figuring out what the legislation is not
just pre-cooking something from the
White House exactly if something gets 60
votes in the Senate is there any chance
it could get a majority of Republican
votes in the house that is the that is
the big question and that is what's
really but deviling members this week as
they try to sort this out because Paul
Ryan has said will hold a vote in the
house so long as it's on something
President Trump
supports well we know he has those four
things he'd like to do 1.8 million
dreamers legalized border security money
changes to family based migration and
ending the diversity lottery Republicans
have proposed that and there will be a
vote on it in the Senate and it probably
won't pass so at that point they have to
sit there and go what can we take away
or what can we add to it to get the 60
and then hope that the president likes
it and then hope that's so what on the
substance is the house not liking that
proposal in which in the Trump proposal
no they like the Trump Republicans like
the term proposal the problem is
Democrats don't and there may actually
be a fair number of Republicans who
don't want to vote for it either because
they have concerns perhaps with the
Train migration issues so you know it's
just one of those trick
ones that we don't know exactly how it's
gonna end and of course they're running
up against a March 5th deadline an
arbitrary deadline set by the president
any plans on possibly extending that so
the White House has said repeatedly the
deadline is March 5th
but courts are still thinking about this
and what what exactly should be the
scope of the program so Homeland
Security still has to accept visa
renewals and is still protecting it so
it's conceivable that the program could
continue through the summer switching to
the Rob Porter and the sexual abuse and
domestic violence allegations that have
been leveled there what oversight are
some of them are those in Congress
saying that they want especially when it
comes to the security clearance process
Democrats last week it was like every
hour there was another Democrat calling
for some kind of an investigation or
questions to be answered the problem is
the White House sends most of those
emails right to the delete folder yeah
but you have a dozen aged do don't have
permanent security clearances one of
which the president's son-in-law who
might be reading the presidential Daily
Brief every day yeah and and and
Republicans so far have refused to
really take up the issue at all saying
that you know this is something for the
FBI to deal with they go with the
argument that folks in the
administration right over the weekend
that there's a backlog and they're
dealing with it but I think at this
point given that you have somebody who
was accused of domestic violence who was
handling the sensitive information from
one Republican on the Senate
Intelligence Committee about that not
not publicly but I think we know
privately they've got concerns with this
absolutely just the question is you know
what are they gonna do what are they
gonna to stop them because they say look
these people work at the pleasure of the
president if he wants them to work for
him
there's very little we can do to stop
them I'm quickly infrastructure bill
down on arrival yes about is about it
stalled as the traffic out on the ED
okay thank you so much great to see you